Вже 25 років, як Петро Зуєв на службі у Бога.
Церковне життя розпочав фактично тоді, коли стався розкол Української православної церкви:
на Московський та, як тоді стверджувалось, неканонічний Київський патріархат.
Як і тоді, так і зараз для отця Петра важливо служити в істинній узаконеній церкві.
Ні, це не церква окупанта. Це такий складний соціальний  організм,
де є і прихильники автокефалії, їх чимало, так і дійсно так звані послідовники "русского міра" -
люди, які себе культурно і церковно ототожнюють з російською церковною традицією і культурою.
Отець Петро уважно стежив за новинами зі Стамбула.
Рішення Синоду Вселенського патріархату про підтримання автокефалії
Українській церкві вважає історичним і справедливим.
Адже надання томоса може нарешті визначити майбутнє значної частини проукраїнського крила
Української православної церкви Московського патріархату.
Яке, як прогнозує отець, захоче перейти в єдину помісну православну церкву.
Я не думаю, що це буде якийсь мій особистий вибір
я думаю, це буде частина духовенства, єпископату,
і будемо діяти не індивідуально, а колективно і соборно.
Після рішення Священного синоду про продовження надання томоса
наступний крок - це скликання Всеукраїнського об'єднавчого собору
та обрання голови єдиної помісної української церкви.
У прес-службі УПЦ Київського патріархату вже назвали
і попереднє місце проведення зустрічі - собор Святої Софії у Києві.
До середини листопада, часу коли Синод Вселенського патріархату вчергове збиратиметься,
планують обрати очільника Церкви.
Це нині найгостріше питання, як і те, скільки ієрархів УПЦ Московського патріархату
приїде на об’єднавчий cобор та як на практиці відбуватиметься об’єднання.
Будуть складності з об'єднанням єпархій, наприклад.
Бо в багатьох областях є по дві, по три паралельні православні структури,
відповідно, у кожної з них є свій очільник - єпископ місцевий.
Як ці єпископи будуть збиратись, як дивитись одне одному в очі,
хто буде головним, а хто помічником.
Кому перейде майно церковне. Це важливі речі.
Суперечки виникнуть і від банального: як називатиметься церква.
Адже логічну назву "Українська православна церква" вже "зайняв" Московський патріархат.
Доведеться або вигадувати нову назву, що теж є нелогічним,
або, приміром, через закон Верховна Рада може змінити статус УПЦ,
щоб обов'язково зазначалась приналежність до Російської православної церкви в Україні.
Про позицію УПЦ Московського патріархату
Deutsche Welle хотіла безпосередньо розпитати у їхнього вищого духовенства.
Однак на обіцяне інтерв'ю митрополит Павло,
намісник Успенської Києво-Печерської лаври, так і не з'явився.
Просто ми домовлялися з ним, і вже чекаємо дві години.
Він не зможе.
Окрім об'єднання українського православ’я, про яке так мріє отець Петро,
томос - це ще й шанс для старту реформи Церкви.
Менше формалізму і правил. Більше зрозумілих сучасним парафіянам меседжів.
Може змінитись і мова служби - українська в усіх церквах.
Утім, російською та старослов'янською, на вимогу громади, також правитимуть.
Врешті, усі нюанси священнослужителі мають обговорити і прийняти на об'єднавчому соборі.
А враховуючи те, що у церковників спроби об'єднатись виникали не раз,
можна прогнозувати, що домовлятись буде непросто.